okay today I'm going to talk to you
about natural selection natural
selection is basically the driving force
behind evolution so it's how a species
change over millions of years to become
new species so the first stage is the
idea that we have different organisms
born that have variation so here I have
two rabbits apologies for my bad join
that have that are born with variation
so within a population
there is always variation variation just
means variety differences so some
rabbits might be born with small is and
some rabbits might be born with big is
there's just that natural variation
between members of the same species now
the important thing is that the
variation between species could give one
of them a survival advantage now what
that means is this one here might be
more likely to survive because it has
better hearing so it has a survival
advantage so if I imagine I have a Fox
coming along right here again apologies
for my terrible drawing Fox coming along
I could see that this one is more likely
to hear the Fox comment and is more
likely to escape whereas this one is
less likely to hear the Fox come in so
it's more likely to get eaten so I could
see that this one would get eaten and
this one would survive that natural
variation has given a survival advantage
this means that this rabbit here with
the gene for slightly longer ears is
more likely to be able to reproduce to
produce more rabbits also with those
bigger ears
as well so we can see this is how
natural selection works we have the idea
of variation between members of the same
species we have a particular
characteristic that provides a survival
advantage because of that characteristic
they are more likely to survive
therefore they're more likely to
reproduce and therefore that gene so the
gene here for the bigger is is more
likely to be passed on to the next
generation to their offspring now this
process is not a fast process this
process can take millions and millions
of years it can take many many hundreds
of thousands of different generations
but that is the main mechanism behind it
so just to summarize natural selection
is how it's basically the driving force
behind evolution it's how we have
changing in organisms over a period of
time it's based on variation between a
population a particular characteristic
providing a survival advantage therefore
that particular gene be more likely to
be passed on to the offspring because
that individual has lived long enough to
be able to reproduce apologies for the
Fox and thank you very much